Moussavi
j'en ai marre
nicolas sarkozy sait qu'il fait peur
lors d'un banal même de temps en temps
attendez je regarde
les organisateurs qui est inquiète
mais que le logement commémoration le
pentagone
mais dans son propre camp
la lorgnette
l'epa s'inquiète-t-elle paz à l'armée
à ne pas alerter
nous sommes dans un temps de
communication
depuis le 6 mai
et le faut s'inquiéter de rien
une confiance
j'ai changé
et un jeu de la droite décomplexée
aujourd'hui je suis un président sans
complexe
je parle à tout le monde
je vais dans les cantines
je rencontre des ouvriers
je vois les agriculteurs
et puis c'est tout
je cours sans cesse
je cours encore je cours toujours
un morceau de d'éloquence enfin je
pense que
on retrouve un peu le personnage de
françois hollande qui sait c'est qu'ils
vont assez bien ma vie manier la langue
c'est quelque chose parfois debout
humoristique au foyer avait un côté
humour danse un temps sa façon de
présenter les choses il ya un côté
évidemment très heureux dans un
meeting politique
mais c'est vrai qu'elle est toute une
série de reproches qui sont faits au
président pour elle
le parc ont tué des traits qui sont
assez spécifique de lance christophe
dumont un peu plus la raffinerie
consistant à dire il a peur de
lui-même quand il se regarde dans la
glace les choses comme ça là on
retrouve un peu ce personnage dont l'une
aurait été quand même pas perçu par
les gens parce que c'était faux numéro
au second degré ça c'est trop subtil
pour être perçue par fadela amara mon
avis les meilleurs moments de françois
hollande ce sont les mêmes moments ces
petits qui sont encore un peu pas
toujours les les mieux perçue par
l'opinion sait il y avait un côté chez
lui
csi de retraite
même parfois assez cruel dans sa
manière de de de porter comme ça avec
des traits d'humour
et on retient plutôt de lui le côté
plutôt lisse plus tôt que plus tôt
donc moi je pense qu'il a égaré un
côté un peu double chez lui
la droite ne veut pas que la droite
on peut la comprendre
nicolas sarkozy
mais plus de l'alluré il faut dit-il
le classement
et le révèle le daily mirror
il ya neuf ans
pour rappel les randonneurs un très bel
exemple
de de l'hymne du type de communication
de françois hollande il est magnifique
et dans un rôle de conteur raconte une
histoire
elle vous l'a d'ailleurs très bien
cherchait dans notre propre histoire ses
références
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avoir trois ou
quatre fois de suite le même scénario
en fait
jusques aux points culminants killer
gens qui auraient quand même pu quitter
jusqu'à
c'est dur pour lui car
d'abord mitterrand comme référence
et ça c'est magnifique c'est vraiment
con c'est vraiment de la structure du
compte un bébé et enfant de 7 ans
c'est un conteur
mettez-vous un peu à sa place
vous seriez de droite
ce que vous n'êtes pas
j'en conviens
vous y avez droit
laetitia chevalier blanc comme
référence d'autant que sur mare
à bord du gouffre après de bons outils
alors qu'hier nous parle aussi de
spécialisation de fonction
dans un cas comme ça le candidat
rassemble et
kemp ce n'est pas lui qui est candidat
la premier secrétaire attaque et se
fait élire
quand même
une spécialité de l'eau france
politique bon et là il faut
reconnaître que c'est assez cruel
c'est d'ailleurs eux plus tôt étant
assez rapide si marseille fait exprès
puis ceux de la polémique même si
c'est vrai
querquevillais dans l'histoire de
béthune tous les pays du monde
les grandes avancées sociales ou
technique bien sûr c'est que ce travail
d'une séance a été levée
c en était faite par atteint par la
gauche mais alala il faut pas accrocher
en cours pour trouver une direction
et surtout moi j'ai l'impression de
toujours ce qu'il veut
avec la gauche française c'est que la
gauche française et les 15 ans
convaincu qu'elle a raison tout
simplement parce qu'elle est la gauche
française mais ça parce qu'ils
adoptent et ça ne me suffit
et quand nicolas françois hollande
l'arrogant pourquoi parce que ce
manquement de sarkozy ce moment sarkozy
en un mot je pense pas qu'avec pour les
jeunes acteurs
même si peut-être sur le fenua raison
mais je pense pas que ses idées
c'est une tactique
efficace d'accord
je pense que les électeurs n'aient pas
de nous mais pas du tout
je pense que les électeurs voient très
bien
% apprécient
le parti socialiste le chef du parti
socialiste si le seul moyen en que moyen
qui ne trouva
pour contrer
sarkozy c'est de se moquer du monde
conséquence que
si m à la limite c'est contre-productif
m gagner des élections il faut
convaincre les électeurs par des
militantes et militants sont déjà
convaincus
les téléspectateurs il n'aime pas ceux
qui prennent
des positions
violente d amende symbolique mais ceux
qui prennent des positions violentes il
n'aime pas ceux qui sont agressifs il
n'aime pas ceux qui fabriquent des
clivages b les téléspectateurs si
j'ose dire sont comme nicolas sarkozy et
ségolène royal tyreke ils ne rêvent
que de toutes façons à l'arrivée et
un rassemblement mais on voit très bien
quand on prend la liste des gens qui
sont les plus populaires ce sont
toujours les plus consensuels qui sont
les plus populaires c'est par hasard
et il a appelé à la barre
j'ai changé at-il dit
wade avait lié à sa destination
si la changer
c'est qu'il n'était pas bien avant
fès il a changé
cd aura pas lieu après
doute que ces efficace c'est pas
efficace
les meetings et accès
13 si on aime sa femme maxine 12 rebonds
quand il est là le françois il est
surtout là pour eux
pour galvaniser son propre parti ses
propres militants et le coureur amenez %
mais des foules
militante d'europe m travers les lignes
- les semaines de campagne et qui vont
être longs et manque
hélas pour eux
pourrait être le le même
l'une des parties la première partie du
spectacle c'est très bien que le soir
ce qui sera repris ce serait socialement
le discours de ségolène sûr ce
compact présidentielle donc il le fut
un temps laissé filer
billy pays sera d'où l'utilité
quelque chose
la fois intéressant mais il peut être
un peu de prémonitoire nom dans ce
document de ségolène royal me fait son
entrée habituel durant cette campagne
n'est qu'une chanson me faites sur
mesure tout pour célébrer l'année de
la dame woerth mais madame ségolène
royal et pour finalement françois
hollande qui était à la tribune qui %
- sosa pâtiront et qui s'éclipse
au modèle paternel à icc services et
leur offrir de fannie mae et un nom ne
se croisent pas ne se parlent pas mais
n'apparaissent pas ensemble absolument
et il apparaît presque comme monsieur
le doyen l'europe
des fonds de pension légale
belga cyrille lejas camara remercie
il salue la volonté
mais au regard de notre réunion avec
nous
pourquoi payer une part l'amusé il ya
quelque chose qui qui fait rire dans sa
façon de date
de faire allusion à la vague actuelle
de ségolène t2 de la ségolène
absente
et en même temps et quelque chose qui
pourrait projeter pour cent au niveau
médiatique a fait ressortir alors à ce
moment-là l'absence là c'est plutôt
quelqu'un qui s'amusent de la situation
et qui pourra
en oeuvre' non effectivement chez les
pros je suis honorée et s'amuse avec
eux mais c'est pas apple pour l'instant
je suis pas et je crois pas que
françois dans ses relations et
ségolène est un moment ou un autre
l'on vide de terrasser ou deux passer
des messages par la télévision qu'ils
soient dans une autre commune
quelqu'un qui s'amusaient situation
mélodies qui s'amusent de la situation
mais de telles situations
ici c'est beaucoup amusé du fait du
succès
elle le monsieur madame a et pour que la
campagne électorale
c'est vrai qu'il avait une situation un
peu particulière puisque pour la
première fois on avait un premier
secrétaire
qui était elle aussi à la ville le
compagnon de la connaître à la
présidentielle à l'alternance des
flots de la seine
intéressante que la postérité
c'est immédiat sur le fait qu'il faut
pas compagnons sont finalement
déroulées
c est à se normaliser le premier
secrétaire elle est la candidate
franchement ces appels qui est la
candidate et et lui il ne peut faire que
de l'accompagnement
ils guettent il est un contrepoint
utiles rappelons que concernant
savernois yale c'est plutôt le roi a
dû mobiliser 10 ans qui fait
apparaître c'est pas du tout rouge
c'est pas demain
distancié vis-à-vis d'elle ses
distances vis-à-vis du midi toujours de
sensibiliser
et deux qui il n'y a eu ni mort qui nous
submerge je dirais même qu'elle confond
le handicap mais il aimait mes joueurs
qui aiment les voitures de laquelle il
sait ce que je vous dis il ne peut pas
s'empêcher d'être lucide et quand
même il est de nature caustique quand
il est lucide ne peut pas s'empêcher de
le dire de façon drôle ce qui fait que
les gens comprennent encore plus
facilement
il ya un côté a priori un côté
on voit toujours un peu mystérieuse
pierre keller une manière
de présenter les choses avec cette
adresse et qui n'ont aucun sens
6% mais en évidence comme à une sorte
de décalage permanent csc comme la
comisca peu dépité à lire on a
l'impression que c'est un rire qui %
critique
qui suscite en fait des interrogations
ces palettes c'est pas le rire franc
c'est le rire un peu angoissant
finalement par rapport à la jeune
ailière et sévices couple ce coupé
décalé aussi qu'on a vu ce se produire
en permanence alors qu'on se pouvait se
dire les parents font plaisir à
tabasser c'est un couple non plus en
fait il a toujours soutenu le peuple
c'est en tout cas été justement
complété en sorte d'être la candidate
était soit son plus fidèle
le lieutenant va pas du tout ça c'est
pas du tout passé comme ça
le message est clair les etats-unis
envoient par l'entreprise en sa qualité
mais ça je n'en vois pas
il fait percevoir
le fait inutiles qui sont par moment le
temps en temps de se faire un élève la
ségosphère et puis les seules ferlaino
nous devons nous rassembler dans
l'ensemble la gauche alors que le poids
le plus facile de rassembler la gauche
ce serait tellement mieux
s'il n'y avait que les socialistes à
gauche
encore que
quand on connaît les socialistes
cassano de respect c'est typique de
françois hollande
leur voix sur le ps qui vivent là il a
un humour assez caustique et on voit
qu'il est très consciente de la
situation des divisions internes et
cetera en plus elle est dotée de ces
rassembler la gauche c'est une sorte
d'incantation va rassembler rassembler
rassembler
pourtant tout le monde est divisé mais
tout le monde ensemble n'est pas autour
de lui
et pour le nouveau françois hollande
évidemment en tant que gay c'est le
gardien du temple assez c'est lui qui
avait aidé clés du parti
et dans le rôle est justement de
rassembler va avoir cette augmentation
perpétuelle at-elle permis de rester ne
disant pas nommé secrétaire du ps ça
lui a permis de durer
on peut se demander si c'est la bonne
stratégie c'est que c'est l'homme de la
synthèse que l'homme du consensus entre
les grandes manifestations des pièces
que c'est la bonne stratégie pour
gagner ça c'est autre chose
ce n'est pas facile cette gauche
ce jugement vient de signaler que les
socialistes encore que
même si avec les socialistes
ce ne sera pas si simple
j'en ai bien conscience
il peut pas s'empêcher de d'une
certaine lucidité il est compris
vis-à-vis du ps et compris vis-à-vis
de la gauche avec compris vis-à-vis de
lui-même alors évidemment quand on est
trop lucide sur soi
qui conçoit
c'est un peu paralysant
et vous savez un handicap pourquoi le
seul handicap quand on est trop lucide
sur soi-même en données on a tendance
à peu à s'analyser pour soi-même au
lieu de 2 j irai de prendre des
initiatives
je vais commencer
pas parler de nos dépôts
cette propension que nous avons pour le
débat
qui va jusqu'à la division
cette amour pour la magie des mots
qui va jusqu'au fiasco des armes parfois
cette mauvaise conscience tout d'abord
en permanence
et qui peut tourner au mauvais esprit
au départ
être assez à gauche jusqu'au point
de jeter la suspicion sur nous-mêmes
d'abord c'est un constat très juste
l'historien que je suive l'historien et
politologue et historien % approuvent la
gauche en france
comme nombre d'autres pays en
particulier l'italie mais la gauche en
france est caractérisé par son ou sa
tendance à se déchirer et à se
diviser à scissionner
scissiparité a explosé comme ça en
permanence et se hisse c'est une
tradition de la gauche française
on est en europe sur un rassemblement de
sensibilité et personnalité
et c'est vrai que c'est jamais simple
d'avoir à opérer ce rassemblement la
banque ce que je crois aussi
et elles sont
à la fois en europe sont getty qui
s'accroît quand les états nous disons
dans un essai sur caussade rassembler
les socialistes
après c'est toujours plus facile de
rassembler à la victoire
et quand on tourne on connaît elle une
défaite comme celle de 2002
outre les compteurs sont remis à zéro
eh bien il faut gérer personnalité des
ambitions
à l'approché des ego
et donc
ça suppose beaucoup de patience et de
diplomatie pour arriver ali garder tout
le monde
dans la même veine
j'aime la vie chaque camarade
les socialistes
sont de retour
françois hollande
le roi chef de file du ps il ya été
dans des conditions évidemment %
catastrophique
tout aurait pu aussi jouer
au lendemain de une autre défaite et
quelle défaite injuste que l'ol
nous aurions pu
le reggaeman
succombez aux surenchères
au coeur de l eau de délicieux
et que quel que soit le parti socialiste
est uni en son sein et parfois même ne
pas le digérer
et donc nous avons su surmonter ces
épreuves et
engager une réflexion collective de
qualité
j il a hérité d'un parti totalement
déstabilisé
pour cent après % et un échec
politique politique électorale qui
était gigantesque
au front
c'est probablement la raison pour
laquelle il est aussi bien entre eux
sont en parlant mais ses preuves dans la
raison pour laquelle il a en permanence
données % et la priorité au
rassemblement un l'unité ou noir au
consensus au lendemain de cette terrible
défaite de cette humiliation de ce
traumatisme
lionel jospin n'est plus là
lionel jospin des polars donc c'est
l'une des grandes figures du socialisme
qui a pris sa retraite tôt évidemment
on s'étonne que m le choc des ambitions
mais aussi pour le lycée affrontements
sur les stratégies à mener
et qu'est-ce qui essaye de faire
françois hollande glissaient à lyon de
reconstituer le parti d'abord
l'unité du parti ça c'est
incontestable il est au-de d'avoir une
politique essaie d'expliquer les raisons
de la défaite mais là évidemment le
lien d accord et à ceux qui pensent que
jospin échoué parce qu'il était
passé à gauche et puis ceux qui
pensent que justement au jeu spore le
maïs mais parce que il n'a pas encore
porté jusqu'au bout la révision
de l'ensemble de la politique du parti
socialiste et françois hollande se
tenir tous ensemble c'est-à-dire du
réformisme
mais aussi à gauche
il est arrivé
dieu merci
l'affairé terry
il est jugé peu pratique
le doublement de l'avenir de la marque
eh bien non
c'est bernard thibault
nous sommes en bonne position dans le
fonds de retraite
le pays est justement que le parti de m
à sa gauche où il était françois
hollande qui était absente militants
comprendre certainement cela requiert
qu'il doit à la fois constituer un
parti réformiste de culture de
gouvernement et en même temps répondre
à cette attente de gauche à cette
sensibilité de gauche qui est présente
dans le parti
et qui s'est manifesté un contrat dans
un autre moment de ce congrès
l'ordure remarquable discours de
lancement du scar enflammé la salle
pour la défense de la laïcité
le marché de l'art
à propos de la future contribution peut
le faire un peu peur
sans que cela semble s'opérer
xu nous verrons dans quelques heures
le landais plus l'europe
par sa filiation religieuse
et entraîneur lyonnais
le sport est plus rapide plus rares
il faut faire preuve de sagesse
il ne peut rien lui dit-elle
pour voir les problèmes au cas par cas
eh bien nous
quel est le bilan
que la république ne se défend pas au
cas par cas
on a l'impression que françois hollande
était convenu dès hier à la sortie
plus de cela j'ai eu une très soulagé
buro+ fait plus partie
il est à sa tête on peut peut-être
par désespoir milla
non non chronologique
les échéances électorales de 2004 et
en 2004 hélène pourquoi pas penser
plus loin
c'est certainement
ce qui suppose comme question
je ne pensais qu'à ce moment-là il se
voit éliminé le candidat
je ne sais pas si sombre candidats mais
johnny ne souffre pas pourquoi il ne se
pose pas cette question
c'est quand même la logique vous êtes
premier secrétaire du principal parti
de position jusqu'ici
m mais le premier secrétaire ont été
candidats
tout le monde est d'accord pour le fait
que vous dirigez sur le fait que vous
dirigez ce parti
c'est normal que dans le système de la
cinquième république vous pensiez que
pas une candidature mieux quand même
des affrontements assez récurrent est
assez je l'aurais socialiste
il faut se rappeler référendum interne
du ps sur le traité constitutionnel
européen depuis
le référendum heures à l'extérieur
nationale inc qui est alors encore vu
s'affronter une partie de la gauche avec
pour cent et une partie du ps avec
l'autre partie du ps puis il est réelle
le congrès du mans qui a fini par une
synthèse métiers des commandes
commencer par heure par la position
assez fort entre les différentes
enseignes du ps
préalable
le premier secrétaire de tous les
socialistes qui arrive
que se passera-t-il après ça m'a foutu
mon accord comment il a fait pour
réussir la synthèse c'est quoi sa
recette françois
c'est un homme d'une ambition
personnelle c'est pas l'homme d'un clan
et donc il a toujours cherché à faire
prévaloir l'intérêt général du
parti socialiste
et donc or on peut reprocher beaucoup de
choses mais pour ce qu'il a toujours
réussi parce qu'il avait un
comportement personnel quittait pas sur
lui la norme de paiement hahaha
réconcilier les différentes parties en
présence à la fed allait amener à
discuter ensemble et puis à trouver le
modus vivendi et pour les années qui
suivent
il faut maintenant la difficulté du ps
ça
réponse mais la sécu et c'est ce qui
rend les choses très compliquées pour
info la secrétaire
c'est que elle sonnerait table ronde
majorité
elle est donc quand on est dans une
situation en cours font chacun dispose
de 20 à 25% du psa et à chaque fois
que le premier fait mouvement les deux
suivants les trois suivants
pour les chercheurs le pied pour éviter
que quelqu'un prenne en otage notre
durable
et donc pour cent dans une situation où
le kirpan interdisait aussi au premier
secrétaire d'avancé exactement comme
il l'entendait et sebha on est loin de
période à l'intérieur avec des blocs
ceux qui sont beaucoup plus homogène -
est beaucoup plus élevé qui permettait
au premier secrétaire avoir les
coudées plus franches donc chez france
mais aussi une obligation
qu'était celle de trouver aussi et le
compromis pour pouvoir faire avancer le
ps quel est le bon moment moi aussi j'ai
réfléchi
tout allait bien et j'ai eu beaucoup
consulté
nos manuels
jeudi soir à terme areva a cédé 213
normale
quelle est la plus belle à l'action que
nous ayons gagné
présidentielle
mais les 980 quand elle était enfant
il est le deuxième
on va s'y répandre la première je vois
pas qui aurait la deuxième en or
c'est la plus belle 80
quant à ce que françois mitterrand a
été
candidate a annoncé sa candidature
novembre 1980 et bien je vous suggère
trois hommes étaient en effet en parle
plus malhabile d'entre nous le plus
mauvais stratège
le moins bon de le candidat je vous
suggère de reprendre le même
calendrier que tu nous a fait gagner
promettent 1980
il ne faut pas faire la comparaison avec
pierre françois mitterrand françois
mittérrand de type et 1965
et surtout après 174 ect ect
de la gauche
en france il était accepter ou est
contesté par michel rocard à la droite
est déçu j'avais d'abord à l'afp
à la gorge serrée dans l'actu sur me
suffirait de mandela
en ouvrant ses adieux et le ps avait la
france avec un françois mitterrand à
aller à être un autre candidat
en fait transports le grand paris
cinq six semaines début 2007
deux personnes
dréno bp prépare le ps a accepté a un
ça va candidat
un bel élu françois hollande qui est
de l'ordre de mar 40 il est apprécié
par la gauche
en tenue orange
tu de suite les daaf dans son bureau de
paix mais faire ça que le père
elles rendront
toulon les éléphants en frappant à la
porte pas trop rapide à propos de ces
travaux
denba
on ne disons-nous moi
et cet égard avec un pape a accepté
qu'à à l'idée de primo ce penneteau
par escarpins aucune
serein il serait alors pas à 2 3 euros
à vos belles actions par six mois avant
l'élection
qui soit accepter comme
le leader
pour l'ofsp
parti pour gagner c'est d'ailleurs pour
cela qu'il est plus
même si certains
le lombard
quant à la floraison des candidats ou
candidates
nous verrons le moment venu
je suis sûr qu'il y aura moins ça
s'est décanté dans un bar elle bat le
mans son choix se à d'abord été
celui installé dans l'été le choix
d'une sorte
d'infirmiers géniale du ps infirmier
parce que c'était même pas un médecin
% et il combattait la douleur il
essayait de de soigner les plaies
mais il durée c'est pas le malade
et en même temps génial parce que
c'est vrai qu'il est arrivé à force de
discuter aarrass tout loisir ensemble
défense qui prenait quand même des
positions
incroyablement contradictoires mais
est-ce que finalement cette obsession
qu'il a eu du mal à rassembler le parti
à appareil était finalement un espèce
de
ainsi il est nécessaire de faire
évoluer c'est pour ça je me dis qu'en
fait ça plus été
un infirmier génial
un médecin efficace il est arrivé
abbas un an
obligeant les rivaux à la sosuco orthez
à un contre les factions pour un
vivre-ensemble donc
il a atteint les objectifs qui se donner
ici au mans
le message de notre congrès
elle a plaidé
simple
les videurs
quant au vu de tous
les socialistes
ce sont désormais tous rassemblés
pour servir la france
amen dans cet objectif était en quelque
sorte stérile
toutes les questions que le ps aurait
dû se poser
au lieu de les poser on les éviter
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas le permis selon
lui d'imposer sa main posé cette
synthèse son savoir-faire
je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui est
plus habile que les autres
une intelligence politique plus grande
que les autres je dis pas que ce soit
vrai dans tous les domaines de
l'intelligence je crois qu'il est une
vraie intelligence politique
que vous avez quand même le statut de
sa fonction
il est donné une autorité
école il a été extrêmement mal hein
dans la façon de
de montrer à chacun des grands pour le
leader e du ps ayant de grandes
ambitions
à quel point l'absence d'accord se
ferait
absurde trimant au détriment de famille
son détriment de strauss-kahn au
détriment de tout le reste
mais quoi donc leur a laissé entendre
qu'il pourrait être candidat avec la
fin d'année riahi et les laisser dans
la course en tête
ic il aura surtout été laissé
entendre à chacun que la synthèse en
force tout le monde sauf lui
ce qui était vrai mais à leur écoute
ça a été vrai à l'arrivée c'est
tout allons je voulais revenir
qui n'a pas été très sympa moi je le
trouve j'ai toujours trouvé les
rencontrer
plusieurs lacunes
mais très souvent
j'ai toujours trouvé très très sympa
avec très intelligent
% est traité et de roland et pourquoi
pas moi
mais très sympa
m et peut-être qui sait pas plus juste
trop sympa
donc nous ne coupons pas assez pour 100
euros qui ont déterminé qu'il n'exerce
pas possibles difficultés et les
philippines
avec un petit peu de monde dans le monde
si peu de
de douala le gggi j'y serai vieux je
serai en france je serai au site aussi
sont aussi sympa possibilité de faire
en sorte que ça parce que pour lui pour
100 e évidemment que l'unité ces
caisses qui ne ce qui comptait donc il
est peut-être prête à mais j'ai
gagné à s'entasser mondiale de la
santé a à z exactement certains partis
aujourd'hui
l'immense piscine réussira à la haye
il faut qui part avec une seule fois
pour 100 élèves
le plus grand problème mains du ps
l'étude de mon premier
à l'inversé quand on a recueilli pour
le moins six ou sept ou huit ou dix
tonnes d'ivoire
% et qui dit
e parfois la même chose mais très
souvent pas la même chose
% et pour 100 euros et surtout des gens
qu'on connaît très très bien je pense
qu'il faut que les socialistes
rassemblant travailler ensemble ce qui
compte c'est qu'il a une majorité
c'était donc une direction sur une
orientation trop de dépenses et de
recettes de l'état est arrivé à la
plus grande efficacité
oui le véritable enjeu
c'est que le parti socialiste
tout tenté
le parti socialiste rassemblés son
adresse au pays
il n'ya qu'un seul le socialisme
c'est cette unité retrouvée
c'est cette unité retrouvée qui le
qualifie même non pour rassembler
l'ensemble de la gauche autour de nous
au mans par exemple tout le monde se
féliciter les commentateurs de la
synthèse qui a débuté aux environs de
la pression de la part des grandes
villes présidentiable même moment sans
tout le monde parle de dan wheldon suis
pas sorti satisfait
à l'aube le lendemain matin le lundi
matin ici les fans italiens d'edison je
trouve au contraire que c est une
synthèse qui était artificiel et qui
avait voulu escamoter les problèmes
beaucoup ont pensé que du coup ça
allait l'aider à être candidat
pour moi je crois pas parce que il il
avait
neutraliser toutes les oppositions mais
il n'avait pas renforcer son autorité
il était arrivé arrondir les angles il
était pas arrivé à se sculpter une
statue
d'ailleurs la façon dont
de ségolène royal a pu démarrer de
manière quasi simultanées
saint-quentin aisne alors même que elle
avait parlé avant
quel à papier et non pas par les
pandores
et puis qu'elle a pu rebondir après
ça prouve bien que le fait d'avoir mis
tout le monde d'accord
m finalement ce n'était pas lui que ça
renforcée
puis elle est partie mais l idée est
de leur côté les verts
désolé et je le souhaite
malgré les derniers jours
les jeunes
ce qui est étonnant dans le cadre de
l'offre
l'une est l'une des questions qu'on
qu'on peut se poser mais sa situation et
prospective
c'est savoir avec qui elle était en
fête dans tout cela la la pensée de
françois hollande ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que pour vous n'est pas
porteur et james était porteur d'un
dans le dos d'un message politique
finalement ça a été un apparatchik 10
pts 5
emc haïtienne pacsés seulement
seulement n a pas ratifié mais en même
temps on
il n'a pas apporté dans le débat
politique quelque chose dont on puisse
dire
voilà quelle était la pensée de
françois hollande voilà ce soit là
quel était le message de françois
hollande si la tenue un message
peut-être son message principal
c'était ce message européen
on a écarté
ceux qui
essentiel
dans le détail
et qui porte précisément sur
tout ce que nous avons fait tous les
socialistes depuis 1957 ensemble
c'est le traité de rome
la culture a permis l'achat 4 à 6 ans
le traité de maastricht en 1992 le
traité d'amsterdam en 1997 et même le
traité de nice en l'an 2000 tout ce que
nous avons fait en somme comme
socialiste
il faudrait que le récuser
d'autant que les socialistes
et cette tentation
je peux les comprendre approché
mais côté socialiste
puis écartée ce que nous avons fait
au format
je m'interroge encore sur leurs
motivations
il a poussé à se dire que
il est lissé lui-même en quelque sorte
piégée alors qu'il était dans une
situation extrêmement favorable sur le
plan personnel et sur le plan de son
leadership il s'est figé dans cette
affaire doit être un homme peut-être
précisément parce que là il avait une
conviction on est très forts qu'il
fallait faire avancer la la france sur
le terrain en terre
et là bizarrement il sait trouver
décalé par rapport à ses propres
deniers c'est une lourde défaite pour
françois hollande c'est une lourde
défaite du parti socialiste
envers l'opinion et ça affaiblit
évidemment la crédibilité de
françois hollande pour l'acier dont
tout lanceur particulièrement passer de
lui parce que c'est lui
qui a voulu plus
alors françois hollande n'est pas là
en dehors de la vois pas parmi les
car françois hollande interviendra
alarcon a relaté des départs
premier secrétaire
enfin en tant que candidate potentielle
certains intervenants mais il est sûr
que si ça arrive
ensemble
il aura fallu 20 minutes plus tard jack
lang
ségolène royal elle n'exerce pas
reconnu
vous le voyez sur cette image saisie
tout à leur égard
pas moins de quatre journalistes et fier
alors en 16 mois de septembre alors
qu'on est seulement tous les
prétendants devaient cesser a déclaré
miranda en soi dernier moment
pourquoi vous avez une explication
houleuse par une explication
le lexique finalement inédite
que le rapport de force à ce moment-là
avait déjà que je te disais qu'il
avait lesley les partisans de laurent
fabius
qu'y avait-il dit
des partisans de la 40'
qui a osé
les partisans de dominique strauss-kahn
qui avait partisan de lionel jospin un
bon moment et et qui avait hurlé la
foule des partisans de ségolène royal
mais comme commune ne s'était pas
vraiment exprimé comme lui avait hissé
le jeu se déroulait sans lui comme il
avait plutôt organiser le jeu des
autres qu'il avait voulu s'y mêler
l'albanie l'avait pas sa base à ce
mandat est comme ça la liste n'ayant
pas sa base disent pouvait pas se lancer
en gros en plus c'est évident que six
lancers se lancer
contre ségolène royal
auxiette ps totalement team imaginables
à ce moment-là il ne pouvait se lancer
dans la course présidentielle
en rivalité avec ségolène royal qu'à
partir du moment où tous les autres le
monde et en faisait le sauveur
ils ne lui ont jamais demandé
la parole était notre premier
secrétaire
à françois hollande
quel bonheur et le premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste
d'abord parce que ça me plaît
de conclure
il y avait huit heures
aucun privilège
simplement la récompense de l'effort
depuis tant d'années
j'ai vu que tous les chantiers du
pas-de-calais
celui-là aussi
il a toujours eu à la fois l'ambition
personnelle
qui est bien légitime pourquoi ce qu'il
nous sommes parmi eux les socialistes
n'ont pas refusé d'être un jour un
candidat plutôt en république mais en
même temps cette volonté de ne pas
prendre ce qui a pu les autres par le
choix personnel qui pouvait réaliser et
donc je n'ai vu cent fois pour l'heure
à la fois chercher à trouver la porte
qui permettrait de rentrer là où il
fallait quand même temps préserver les
chances préserver la réputation
préservée
les espérances de chacun parce qu'il
avait la volonté de ne pas servir à
aucun moment
pour l'idéal comment
qu'est-ce qui manque la mort à
françois hollande l'homme est
intelligent c'est incontestable la ville
est un vrai leader politique il aurait
fait un triomphe sous la quatrième
république un trio c'est un vrai
parlement telle quelle chance
de la manoeuvre tactique il sait faire
du judo politique qui sait faire des
prises à ses adversaires or les
sondages désignent par françois
hollande comme un candidat cas précis
les gens de gauche ou la gauche pourquoi
mais je pense que françois hollande
paye la triple pollution de notre vie
politique des grandes démocraties
occidentales
la personnalisation de plus en plus
marquée e il doit apparaître comme un
leader capable de parler la population
le d'être séduisant pour eux dans le
pays messahel il a du mal à le faire
deuxième point la présidentialisation
ça signifie choisiront aussi un
responsable qui semble crédible pour
occuper une pente posons tous et qu'il
est stratégique hélas c'est pas apple
le problème de la capacité personnelle
de françois hollande ses capacités
intellectuelles en cause
mais c'est la terrible en préparation
mais en tout cas la faible préparation
de l'ensemble du parti socialiste sur
des questions un petit mot clé et puis
le troisième point c'est la
médiatisation la politique est devenue
effectivement un spectacle et si les
gens réclament des stars il est
réclamé aussi en politique donc on
peut jouer d'une manière plus ou moins
raisonner de manière plus ou moins bien
avec ce phénomène de starisation et
là ça passe pas pour plaire à la fois
chercher où il avait pas les atouts
pour peut-être enfin les atouts pour
cent et ce qu'il faut incriminer
différents points de son physique sa
posture est bonne c'est terrible à dire
parce que c'est ces redoutables mais
c'est comme ça oui il faut alors
rappeler celle de choses simples
que si l'on ne veut pas que la gauche
québec avec la gauche parlant
si on veut pas que la voiture peut
toujours le faire en votant à droite
mais si on veut battre la gauche
avec la droite
et si on veut battre la droite c'est
avec la gauche
nous ne voulons pas évolué d'un poil
candidat et lorient
et public changer aussi
hélas il n'a pas changé issoufou de
son image quelque part ce qui est très
bien à mon âge je préfère ça à
voulu et su mieux que les images
construites larcher médiatisé konaté
c'est l'anti ségolène royal quelque
part ségolène royal était le trac on
tire son image a été laissé une image
ultra construit les journées sean penn
et même de ce que vous ne pouvez pas
prendre une telle ampleur que c'était
ultra calculé tout était ultra
formaté l'hebdo
on ne s'en fout le manifeste est arrivé
tout transpirant j'ai un peu bedonnant
son costume part
je pense que c'est pas de jack lang qui
fait un buzz des réseaux qui sont
impeccables héritage son assassin
bousquet lui aurait dû partir il ya
cinq ans
mais je pense pas et je pense que
en e les autres
on est parti avec 1 55 ans je pense que
après 2002 il m il aurait dû avoir une
norme balayage
de tout pour tous les éléphants
montent de toutes les grandes sections
et les autres saisons c'était aux
échelons
du parti socialiste
et qu'à nous-mêmes
et si je l'avais pas gagnée ils ont
perdu 57 erick et si et si et si
celle-ci ce n'était pas sûre qu'ils
allaient trouver ces passionnés de tous
qui va les trouver quelqu'un
pour contrer
à la sarko qui piqua capable de contrer
sarkozy pour 2007
je pense qu'il ferait appel
leur position
3 avril
la gauche
je crois en fait depuis 1980 ap
n'était jamais allé et que ce que nous
tout pouvoir
totalement le tendon une longue période
cette démission mardi l'assemblée
nationale en 86
mais mi-temps on a été là
perdu la présidence en 1995 mais de
plus en plus tard messi cherche pas elle
est retournée chez une autre
on a passé cinq ans on pourrait trouver
une
d ici on réprime qui nous sont allés
à ce moment-là
deux ans d'exclusion total
duffy hopper ministériel de pouvoir
politique dans le pays
en une semaine nous séparent de
l'épeule en ne se regarder dans la
glace de mer noire des journaux il faut
changer est-ce que cette mandanda était
arrivé pour la gauche en france je ne
sais pas je pense quand même que je
pense franchement que la personne qui va
faire gagner le ps français on ne
prenait pas en compte nous rendre au
camp nou et encore
à
le thème de la femme même façon que
le départ de m
e qui estompez ans déjà en tête des
sondages et qui est vraiment à pied qui
pose un danger sérieux en bord de marne
on prêche prochaines législatives en
angleterre il ya cinq ans je ne savais
pas qui c'était
il ya trois ans on savait pas qui
c'était il ya deux ans réponse avec
leur société
% et hasard je pense qu'il fait il faut
juste du bout du bout du monde outre une
nouvelle mans
mais aussi du renouvellement
% autour du mieux
compréhension véritables acteurs de la
discipline
si on n'aime pas
si le québec
même si on apprécie les biologistes et
on a apprécié le débat
si on fait de la politique en discuter
et cetera et cetera si on va faire une
différence très tard
% à 6 ans et socialement de la mapei
été et tous ces arguments
%
bon eh bien non
mais les coutumes mais ce qu'il faut ces
de la discipline cf
fini les années 80 c
finies les années 90' c'est fini
de même le prévert partie de cet essai
de l'état
cette faute ali
le nouveau psg
la nouvelle france qui est en train de
se former
et s'il ya une chose que
pour cent et le jour où il sera à
nouveau
woerth à un citoyen ou soit un
parlementaire parmi d'autres il
retrouvera aussi une forme de liberté
mais j'espère qu'ils emploieront dire
qui il est vraiment parce que pour ceux
qui le connaissent et qui l'approchent
pour elle il ya une profondeur que peu
le connaissent
et pour cent moi j'ai géré finalement
à se relever c est de ces années
passées avec lui c'est qu'il n'est pas
suffisamment souvent révélé sa vraie
personnalité on en a fait quelqu'un me
fabien il est au contraire extrêmement
vif on n'a fait que quelqu'un ceux qui
étaient uniquement grâce à la
synthèse il est aussi fiable capable
heureux d'avoir une pensée avec ses
membres tranchés et la voir pour une
capacité aaaah comprendra saisir le
réel plus vite que d'autres et à le
comprendre et analyser et même à
proposer la solution équipe qui qui est
avec qui son avis et les meilleurs c'est
vrai que l'on a peut-être que dans la
nouvelle vie qui se prépare ailleurs à
eux pour lui cette occasion de but de
présenter un autre visage les autres
images à la télé la nôtre notre
destin
je pense que le 8
à lui je pense qu'il a raison
au moins autant de talent politique que
les autres pour être candidat
alors évidemment il peut pas le sais
pas maintenant que ça se décidera à
sa sauce dix ans dans deux ans dans
trois ans
il faut que entre temps qui se veut
reconstruite dans l'opinion
une personnalité non plus de chef de
parti
mais m 2
ténors politiques l iran vocation à
être candidat autrement dit ça veut
dire qu'il faut qu'il y ait une ligne
politique qu'ils soient pas la
résultante des lignes politiques du ps
mais sa ligne politique dans les années
il n ya jamais eu par exemple en
matière d'alliances
bon ça veut dire surtout que les fous
qui est des visites guidées hollande
on a eu des tactiques langues mais
attention il veut être candidat il faut
des idées hollande flocons
l'identifiera une demi-douzaine de
grandes options fermement exprimée
original équipe d'ici mais un autre
personnage vous pensez que possible
justement pour quelqu'un qui n'a jamais
et qu'elle aimait défendu des idées
hollande ont défendu on lance qu'il a
on a tout à fait l'attitude
intellectuelle
il faudra qu'il ne lui faudra où il
faudrait qu'il emmenait le désirent
ça y est tu es qui peut le savoir mais
mais je suis sûr que c'est quelque
chose qui ne peut se faire qu'en
plusieurs années
et donc connu n'a pas beaucoup de temps
pour se décider et paradoxalement si de
se construire une autre personnalité
dans l'opinion
et je crois que c'est un préalable pour
que puisse être candidat m il faut
qu'ils se mettent maintenant je
mer